I know that like me you probably grew up
very Roman Catholic yeah did you do the
whole nine yards were you uh
choir boy you know altar boy did the
funeral homes did you do the funerals no
I was the because they could tell that I
could actually enunciate pretty well
they made me the What's called the
lectern which is the the guy who reads
you know certain passages we didn't have
that yeah well they would you know it's
usually like the priest does it but they
would have someone step in and read a
couple of passages and they were like
this guy can enunciate and he knows yeah
literally they're like this kid
enunciates and then and in Boston nobody
enunciates
you know everyone else just sounded like
they had a bunch of clam shells in their
mouth and then I and the corner I was
saying and on the third day he rose
in fulfillment to the scripture he's
seated at the right hand of the father
he'll come again in glory to judge of
the living and the dead
they're like we got to use this guy you
know so but they had me doing that but I
envied the you know
like you get to ring the bells I didn't
get to ring the bells that was a bell
guy
yeah it's like I'm getting guys for a
bank job do we have a bell guy I'm a
bell guy
I held the water you ever held the water
for the
foreign
[Laughter]
that was at Saint Ignatius St Lawrence
I worked a couple of churches
this is the 70s I'm an older guy than
you but the 70s was really the time to
be in a Catholic church I'll tell you
something uh but no I were just I
remember we had a we had a priest that
used to
um
all of our priests you know were pretty
much they were either Italian or Irish
but we had one guy
his his thing was to he had always had
change in his pocket and as he was and
he was real like a club comic and he
would Jingle the change in his pocket
and walk around and you know and and
give the homily and it was always in
like a very folksy and kind of working
jokes in and stuff and then he'd always
end the app and and the uh mass by
saying uh they're supposed to just say
um you know you know uh so go in peace
to love and serve the Lord you know
that's what they're supposed to do at
the end of the mass and be like go in
peace to love and serve the Lord have a
nice day have a nice week see you around
[Laughter]
what's Jesus think about this ending
different did you do confession did you
go to confession that was frozen
confession I didn't know what to say I
would make up oh really yeah I
would say I murdered a man I mean I
would say anything but I never I don't I
didn't confess anything real I I would I
would I mean nothing
I mean there's nothing going on back
then where he's like I didn't walk in
when I was 13 and say yeah yeah
get admitted adultery I mean there's
none of that
you gotta see this Broad
yeah no I did I did all that I did uh
did the confession I went every Sunday
um you know did the um gave the money
Chris my my uh being Italian who you
just give the money and we never put it
in the the envelope that you're supposed
to put in they give you like an envelope
you put it in you know and then you put
your name so you gave you just peel it
off just a just a crisp 20 right into
the uh nice
that made me think of like some wise ass
kid there was the CR the
it was Christmas time and they had this
beautiful crash you know the the little
main the manger and there was a you know
everyone's gathered around you know Mary
and
um you know everyone's there they've all
they're the Shepherds the wise men and
the Sheep the donkey and they're all
looking over in great reverence and
someone some wise ass had taken the baby
Jesus out and put a twenty dollar bill
down
and I remember really thinking that was
funny and my mom swatting me
saying no that's not funny but uh I
don't think they ever found that Jesus